in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion for June 2, on which we commemorate the Holy New
Martyr Constantine, the converted Muslim. Originally from Metalini of Muslim parents,
Saint Constantine showed a strong inclination towards virtue from childhood.
When he was fifteen he became blind, a victim of a magician who had given him a poisoned
potion to drink, and remained confined to bed for three years.
A devout Christian woman, having pity on him, suggested to his mother that she should
plunge him into a miraculous fountain in which he would be cured. As a result, he was able
to take up work in a green grocers with his brother in Smyrna. He was often called to make
deliveries to the Episcopal Palace, where he listened with interest to the Christians.
Through this means the fire of divine love began, little by little, to be kindled in his
heart. However, influenced by bad company, he gave himself over to a life of debauchery
for a time, but he soon realized the wretchedness of his state and decided to travel to mount
Athos to become a Christian. He made his desire known in various skitties and at the great
Lavra, but the frightened monks sent him to the Holy Patriarch Gregory V, who at that time
was living in exile in the monastery of Ividon. The latter listened to him with kindness and
suggested to him that he should prepare himself for six months in the skit of Gavsokalivia.
When the day of his baptism finally arrived, the brilliant piercing light shone from his
face when he came out newborn from the baptismal font. He lived afterwards in the skit as
though free of the body. After venerating the relics of the new martyrs at the skit of
the forerunner of Ividon, he was suddenly seized with the violent desire to imitate them, and
his spirit became constantly preoccupied with this idea so that he gave the impression of
being sad and downcast. He made his project known to his spiritual father, who decided
to test him with a strict fast and increased eschisies for forty days. But, after receiving
a vision, his desire for martyrdom cooled, and he decided to travel to Magnesia to undertake
the conversion of his sister. Arriving in Cedonia, Ayvali, he was recognized
by a Turk, and was just on the point of fleeing to Smyrna when he was arrested and taken
before the Aga. His holy desires were revived by these circumstances, and he confessed without
hesitation that he was indeed of Turkish origin, but had been converted to Christianity.
After a second interrogation before the judge, the Christians of the region hearing of this
case succeeded in infiltrating the prison where he was being kept, to encourage him in the combat
he was about to endure. During the next interrogation, a coppersmith, who had already served as the
torturer of St. George of Kiyos, offered his services again. With diabolical ingenuity, he fashioned
a metal helmet, which he made red hot in the fire, and then placed on the saint's head. He then
squeezed lead balls tightly against his temples with straps, so that his eyeballs eventually popped
out of their sockets. The following night, some devout Christians saw a light coming from the church
of the new martyr George, and enter the prison where Constantine was being kept. Some days later,
when Constantine appeared again before his judges, he asked to be untied. Whereupon he made a large
sign of the cross, saying, now recognize what I am, and do not hope that I will change my mind.
The incensed judge drew his sword and struck the saint's chest with the sign of the cross,
but only his garment was torn, and a resplendent golden cross appeared on his breast.
On about the 23rd of April, in 1819, he was again beaten, and heavy chains were laid on him.
By day he sat, his feet pressed in a vice, and by night he was left hanging in the air by his shackles.
In addition, Satan troubled him with numerous apparitions and temptations,
yet the saint remained firm, encouraged by a young schoolboy who had managed to gain
access to the prison, and who told him of the exploits of Christ's martyrs, while all the Christians
of Cidonia assembled together in the churches of the town and prayed that he might be strengthened
in his confession of the faith. One night he had a vision of the mother of God, who greeted him as a
faithful servant of her son, and announced to him the glorious issue of his combat, as well as the
imminent catastrophe which was about to descend on the town. When Constantine showed himself
immovable, he was transferred to Constantinople, where, after having ardently confessed his faith
to the governor under torture, he was shut up in a public bathhouse. A priest came and offered
to have him set free, but the saint refused, showing him his wounds as signs of his endurance,
and begging him to do nothing, to place no obstacle to the fulfillment of the prediction made
by the mother of God. After two further interrogations, Constantine, sighing, besought the judge to
realize what would profit his own soul, and to be converted to Christ himself. These words roused
the anger of the judge, who struck him in the face, and ordered that he first be tortured,
and then executed by hanging. After his execution on the second of June,
his torturers buried the body of the glorious martyr in a Turkish cemetery, so that the Christians
would be unable to venerate it. Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord,
Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us, and save us.